hi my name is McKenna grace hi I'm Chris
Evans and we're about to do a wired
auto-complete interview and I just peel
these bad boys back yep all right who
Chris Evans look like focus Evans look
like um you know I heard people tell me
when I was younger that I look like
Ricky Nelson who was Kevin's date at the
Oscars it was my mom one year my sister
last year who is Chris Evans frothy
coffee man I don't know what that means
I'm not really a coffee guy to be honest
well you're introducing me to the to the
tea world known for he's very known for
she mapped in America what is Chris
Evans favorite foods favorite food
jellybeans jellybeans jellybeans I don't
know if we're categorizing that is food
but I eat him was having his first movie
well technically it's not another teen
movie I mean I did a couple little
things back in Massachusetts but I don't
think anyone was to call them actually
yeah well the first movie the official
movie was a movie called the newcomers
gasps oh why does Chris Evans like in
real life well he's very huggable he's
very very huggable look at that look at
that
and he's also filled with jelly beans
[Laughter]
[Applause]
did Chris Evans rip a log in half I mean
what a styrofoam I don't that's nobody's
business did Chris Evans quit acting I'm
here on I just Chris Evans drive like a
champ I got the speeding tickets to
prove it
where was Chris Evans have a brother his
name is Scott very funny very talented
Scott okay where did Tristan where did
Chris Evans grow up squared is Chris
Evans keep his boat his boat he was a
bullet she does not have a boat where's
Chris Evans this morning he's at the W
Hotel that's great
yes where is Chris Evans mum from his
money mom she's also from Massachusetts
does Chris Evans actually sing I mean we
sing all the time on the set we sing a
it's American Crew you'll learn about
the consequences and the never ending
life of the internet later does Chris
Evans answer a fan mail uh sometimes it
doesn't always find its way to me does
Chris Evans have an Instagram he does
not doesn't he have a Twitter he does
have a Twitter does Chris Evans do his
own fight scenes she does as much as he
can play the trumpet I tried you know I
think I did a movie or my character
played the trumpet so I I took lessons
not the sounds I know that sounds a lot
better than when I was with Ken Chris
Evans tap dance oh that I can do Oh
topic that I can do maybe well maybe
well sing and tap together you're not
gonna sing just pleased as soon as the
camera goes off we'll do a little
soft-shoe in the hallway Kenny and Chris
Evans drive what is going on with me
yes I could drive very well I'm a
grown-up yes I can drive taking this all
right
what is Chris a star sign stop sign
remember you are a cancer Oh am i I'm a
crab then you're a June what is Chris
Evans diet Jim he's a vegetarian who
only eats jelly bean jelly bean
what is Chris Evans real name Chris
Evans and what Heaven's his hairstyle
that's what it is it's beautiful
nailed it I'm kind of surprising some of
the questions I have one last question
lay it on me can you drive good work it
up